You're an interesting man, Scott Lang.
You're an Avenger.
You have a daughter,
but you've lost a lot of time.
Like me.
Who are you?
I'm the man who can give you more time.
Scott.
You cannot trust him.
I just lost so much.
He can give us a second chance.
He will bring me what I need
for everything you call a life.
We'll end.
You may not want her to watch this.
We had a deal.
You thought you could win.
I don't have to win.
We both just.
Sorry, Cassie.
Ant-Man and the Wasp Quantumania
ready PG 13 in theaters February 17.
Welcome back, everyone.
Is Charlie
Marvel released a brand new Ant-Man
and the wasp Quantumania trailer video
with a whole bunch of new footage
that will break it down.
There's a whole bunch of Easter eggs in.
A lot of you have had questions
about what's going on with Kang
the Conqueror during the movie and what
leads into Avengers five Kang Dynasty.
Like, why is he doing all this?
What is he going to be doing?
If you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos we're doing in IMAX
to give away for the movie.
All you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber.
Just post all your theories
in the comments below
and I'll name a new winner
at the end of this too.
But during the trailers,
Kang keeps talking to Ant-Man,
offering him this bargain.
I can give you more time and that's it.
Man's whole deal is that he wants
to make up for lost time with Cassie Lang.
He lost five years
while he was stuck in the quantum realm.
He needs Scott Lang to help him recover
the device that Janet Van Dyne
stole from his time care, his time
travel device that he keeps sitting in,
in all the trailers here
and all the pictures.
This is the engine that he's
staring at here.
Notice
that there's nothing in the middle of it
here.
But in other trailers,
you see him sticking this glowing orb
in the middle of it.
That's what Jenny Van Dyne stole from him,
stranding him, keeping him
trapped there for all this time.
What have you been asking
what exactly that is?
It's meant to be a device
that allows him to travel
across the entire multiverse
and through the timeline,
not just through his own timeline,
but through all timelines, all over time
and space. Anywhere is possible.
This is the MCU version of the Forever
Crystal,
which is from the Avengers Forever
storyline.
The Forever
Crystal was basically the heart of forever
that Immortals took in changed
into what he called the Forever Crystal,
and it was a device that allowed him
to manipulate all time, basically
make anything that he wanted to possible
combining any aspects of any realities
that he wanted.
Like during the Loki series,
when Miss Minutes is trying to tempt Loki
and Sylvie Kang can reinsert you
into the timeline in a way
that won't break things and make it so
that you won the Battle of the Avengers.
You have the Infinity gantlet
that you killed Thanos,
and you can live with a version of Sylvie.
And no one will think it's weird.
Like it won't break logic
or anything in the comics.
The Immortals
version of Kang,
in other variants of Kang,
other characters can use the Forever
Crystal to accomplish that.
It's kind of like an upgraded version
of the Infinity Gantlet.
If the Infinity Gantlet could control
every single reality,
like the entire multiverse all at once,
whereas the regular Infinity
gantlet is only capable of working
in their own realities.
That's why there are infinite universes,
infinite versions of the Infinity gantlet
in each different universe.
Whereas there's only one forever. Crystal.
Dr. Doom also created a device like this
that he called a doom lock,
which allowed him to affect time like
change time around him on a smaller scale
without changing his own self.
In the comics, Kang also kind of stole Dr.
Doom's time travel platform designs
to build his own first time travel device.
So just more ideas on technology.
The kang is borrowing,
quote unquote, from Dr.
Doom. A lot of Dr. Doom going on here.
Don't worry.
We will see him in the MCU
relatively soon.
The difference with Immortals is forever.
Crystal, is that
it was a much more powerful version
of that idea that it could infect time
across the entire multiverse.
A lot of people also wondering
if they're going to base
some of Avengers 5 Kang Dynasty
on the plot of Avengers forever
because there's basically
a bunch of different Avengers from across
the timeline, like different points
in time, in different realities,
all fighting with
and against versions of Kang.
During that storyline,
they wind up facing multiple variants
of Kang and Mortis and the regular Kang
the Conqueror.
The original story
for that happened in the nineties, and
there are a whole bunch of characters
that they don't have in the MCU right now.
Especially smaller
characters will probably won't see,
so they're going to make
a couple of big changes.
They're also basing
some of the story on Avengers Kang War,
which is a more recent story
that features a version of The Avengers
that's much closer
to what we have in the MCU or what
we will have in the next couple of years.
But just like Avengers, Infinity War
and Avengers Endgame,
even though there were
a lot of Easter eggs
for the Infinity Gantlet storyline,
a lot of it was very different.
They changed a lot of things.
So it'll be the same situation
for Avengers five, Kang Dynasty,
and then for Avengers six Secret Wars.
Here's where Jonathan Majors talks
about Kang's motivation,
like who he is, why he's doing everything,
what's going on inside him,
why he becomes a villain,
why he becomes Kang the Conqueror.
When he was originally known as Nathaniel
Richards, The quantum realm is my
current domain.
That's where I am, you know,
And as the title says, I've conquered it.
And so he's a man isolated,
just there, working it out,
but particularly villains that, yes,
there is the manifestation of the power,
but the the internal power is really the
drive, you know, And I think with Kang,
something that I found so interesting
is that his pain and suffering
and this discomfort and frustration
with society and the world,
and that is so great in him
that that friction has allowed him
to make himself
into the supervillain that you see.
It is that internal friction
that gives him that power.
Now, how it manifests.
Stay tuned. Yeah,
but but yeah,
his heartache is
is great and I think is is is
so massive
he does live up to that
that title of being the biggest baddest
you know MCU villain that we've had.
So notice
when he's talking about his character,
he talks about how he went
from being this misguided scientist
to a full blown Thanos level villain,
like Worse than Thanos, because he's
trying to take down the entire multiverse.
When the Kang Multiverse War,
he implies that being stuck in the quantum
realm for so long, being stranded there is
what turned him into a villain like
he might have been misguided at first,
but being stuck there for so long
just caused him to go a little bit nuts
and stew until he got so pissed off
that that drove him to full blown villainy
and to become Kang the Conqueror.
Conquering the quantum realm
in the way that Janet
Van Dyne explains the quantum realm.
It's like a separate universe
all to its own.
Apart from the regular universe,
meaning that
the rocks that they're standing on here
isn't like the entire quantum realm.
Like it's not one planet.
There's an infinite number
of different worlds, different systems,
different suns at that level.
And Jonathan Majors is basically saying
that Kang came up with his new plan
for destroying the multiverse,
winning the Kang Multiverse War,
creating this new army here,
his new quote unquote dynasty
after he had been stranded in.
That wouldn't have happened if Janet Van
Dyne had not helped him at first.
Like they found each other as scientists,
like, Oh,
we can help each other
escape the quantum Room,
because that was Jennifer
Dean's whole thing.
When she got stuck there.
Kang had also been stranded
there as a regular scientist
before he turned into Kang the Conqueror.
Then she discovered his true ambitions
for the multiverse, was horrified,
sabotaged his time chair
by taking out the power source.
They're in. Abandoned him in his exile.
Then he got pissed off,
conquered the quantum realm,
and they started calling him
Kang the Conqueror.
So they're kind of implying in this movie
that Janet Van Dyne was responsible
for Kang becoming
Kang the Conqueror in everything
that he's going to be doing in Avengers
five Kang Dynasty.
Blame it all on Janet Van Dyne.
And that's meant
to be part of this dark past
that she never wanted to tell her family
about what's meant to be different
about his character from someone
like Thanos, for instance,
is they're calling Kang a man who's at war
with himself like variants of himself
as much as he's at war with The Avengers.
Whereas Thanos was only concerned
with changing this one
universe a616 MCU universe,
the Infinity Gantlet.
In defeating this version of The Avengers,
he wasn't worried
about fighting his younger
or older selves, or even fighting Avengers
from across the multiverse.
The more emotional part of Kang's
storyline,
like where you talk
about all of his frustration
and all of these things that he's lost
this lost time might have something to do
with Ravana Ren Slayer too.
They kind of tease that relationship
during Loki season one and we'll see
Ren Slayer during Loki season two,
but we're going to be seeing
so many variants of Kang.
It'll be interesting
to see how they explain this
version of Ren Slayer and whether we see
other variants of Slayer as well.
In the comics
you really only meet the one version,
but obviously because the way
the MCU is treating things,
there are many different variants
that are going to be popping up
usually in the comics
like Avengers Forever
or Avengers, Kang War or even Secret Wars.
They're really just facing
one version of Kang from different points
in his own timeline,
not from a bunch of different universes.
There is the Council of Kangs,
which is a multiverse version of Kang's
That band together,
and they did tease that during Loki Season
two, like the Council of Reeds
with Reed Richards
from a bunch of different realities,
really hoping
they teased that during the new Fantastic
Four movie in a couple of years.
But we'll see how quickly
they spin up into multiverse stuff
because it's happening
right before Avengers five,
Kang Dynasty and Secret Wars.
But he basically does confirm that
this is going to be the version of Kang
that they'll face during Avengers
5 Kang Dynasty,
implying that he will make it out
at the end of the movie.
It will be interesting to see
what kind of Avengers team
they put together in Avengers
5 Kang Dynasty.
Will it truly be a bunch of Avengers
from across the timeline,
like a bunch of older Avengers
from much earlier points in the timeline
in Avengers from the distant future
because they've done
versions of that in the comics.
Usually the ones from the distant future
wind up being from the vastly different
future, and his characters like Vision,
who don't technically age,
but there's ways that they can do
older versions of younger characters.
Now, a really good example of
that is The Young Avengers.
They are going to use this movie Ant-Man
and the WASP Quantumania
to tease the formation
of the Young Avengers,
but I don't think the actual team is going
to come together for a couple of years.
A version of them could wind up showing up
during Avengers 5 kang Dynasty,
and it's just a version of the team
from the future
with slightly older
versions of the characters.
I know there's also lots of questions
about the other variants of Kang like Iron
Lad showing up on The Young Avengers
because that was a big twist,
like a younger version of Kang that didn't
want to be evil and wanted to be a hero.
That gets into the whole idea of Kang
fighting other variants of himself
the Kang Multiverse War.
Because most of the different variants
don't agree with each other,
it's always possible
we'll see future
variants of Kang
not played by Jonathan Majors
that are pretending
to be other characters,
but post all your theories in the comments
below.
Congratulations techie,
you're the giveaway winner
for my last big Marvel video. Please
email me on the about page of my channel
so I can get your contact details.
My full Last of US
Episode three Video we'll post tomorrow.
Be sure to enable alerts from my channel
so you don't miss that.
Everyone click here for my Last of US
season two teaser trailer
that they just released and click here
for my new trailer for the Flash movie.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone.
Stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one.